à mes côtés toute la famille Galtier les
grands-parents Jean-Marie et Polette
Jean-Marie euh je disais que c'est un
petit peu le fieff galetier chez mojesti
puisque on ne trouve que des galetiers
dans cette dans ce village c'est vrai le
fief des galetiers et tous les galetiers
auourd'hui tous ses oncles son père tout
le monde a jou aujourd'hui si et tout le
monde est content de lui de la bonne
graine donc pour Fabien Paulette je sais
qu'une grand-mère dit toujours du du
bien de son Petitfils mais c'est vous
qui l'avez élevé qui avez faire ses
premiers pas oui oui oui c'est moi qui
l' appris à marcher qu' a appris à
parler qu'il pouponné pendant 3 4 ans
c'est un garçon très très gentil très
affectueux et qui aime bien la famille